OK, so we already discussed earlier, and I
mentioned to you that a man was killed in
Portland, Oregon over the weekend.
And this, as well as some of the other events
of the weekend, despite not stopping Donald
Trump from golfing, did set him off tweeting
completely uncontrollably for hours in the
middle of the night.
And these really were the rantings of a mad
man.
And there, you know, it's it's not normal
for anybody to behave this way on social media.
It's not normal for anybody to be tweeting
this much on social media.
Most people don't have this much time to be
spending so much time tweeting and retweeting
things on social media.
And I mean, listen, when when I see someone
tweeting at messages at me so frequently,
I just mute them immediately.
And we have the president doing this.
And each of these tweets we're going to look
at are so riddled with lies, we could analyze
all of them in detail.
I'm only going to do a couple.
Many of these are sort of illuminating or
informative in some way.
I think there's something we can we can get
from them.
So one of the questions that has been coming
up is why isn't Joe Biden criticizing the
violence and unrest in the streets?
And of course, he has.
But Donald didn't really matter to Donald
Trump.
Donald Trump tweeting, quote, When is slow?
Joe Biden going to criticize, criticize the
anarchists, thugs and agitators in an TIFA?
When is he going remember?
And TFA hasn't killed anyone.
When is he going to suggest bringing up the
National Guard in badly run and crime infested
Democrat cities and states?
Remember, he can't lose the crazy Bernie super
liberal vote.
Well, Biden did actually do that, denouncing.
And it's Trump who has refused to denounce
some of the individuals in some of the violence
that has actually taken place over the last
four days Joe.
Joe Biden put out a statement about this.
And in that statement, he said, quote, I condemn
this violence unequivocally.
I condemn violence of every kind by anyone,
whether on the left or the right.
And I challenge Donald Trump to do the same.
Well, Trump hasn't.
It does not matter if you find the political
views of your opponents abhorrent.
Any loss of life is a tragedy.
Today, there is another family grieving in
America.
And Jill and I offer our deepest condolences.
But it doesn't matter to Trump.
It's the narrative that Biden won't denounce
it and things will be even crazier if Biden
is president.
And it's working on a bunch of people.
Trump also had a two tweet rant about Joe
Biden.
We'll go through some of the lies here.
Joe Biden is coming out of the basement earlier
than his hoped for ten days because his people
told him he has no choice.
His poll numbers are plunging.
Now, that's not true.
There is a tightening in some areas, but Biden's
numbers aren't plunging.
Trump goes on going to Pittsburgh, where I
have helped industry to a record last year.
That's a lie.
And then back to his basement for an extended
period.
His problem is interesting.
He must always be weak on crime because of
the Bernie Sanders radical left voter.
What's amazing on this is that one of the
primary critiques from the Bernie laughed
about Biden is his involvement in the 1990s
crime bill, which, even though it was almost
30 years ago, still is mentioned as Biden
being too much like a Republican on supposed
law and order and crime.
But in any case, you can't talk sense into
these people.
Trump going on.
If he loses them like crooked Hillary did,
he is toast.
And many will vote for me because of trade.
Bernie was good on trade.
Joe must always be weak on crime.
So this is now, you know, the basement stuff
continues in the Joe Biden is weak stuff is
continuing, but it's also completely disconnected
from what Joe Biden is actually doing.
Joe Biden actually has been more visible lately.
Joe Biden is going to be speaking in a few
places.
Trova, Joe Biden's RNC speech, DNC speech,
rather, compared to Trump's RNC speech, was
tethered to reality, unremarkable but completely
reasonable.
Trump then going on to tweet.
The only way you will stop the violence in
the high crime Democrat run cities is through
strength.
Now, remember, whatever violence is going
on now is going on now when Trump is president
and Trump insisting that to stop the violence
that's happening during his presidency, you
need to reelect him.
Doesn't pass the sniff test.
But as I talked about in the last segment,
the chaos helps Trump big picture.
That's scary.
Trump also retweeting a bunch of different
fight videos.
Believe it or not, this is the president of
the United States.
Trump also tweeting attacks on different people,
for example, tweeting Ted Wheeler, the wacky
radical left do nothing.
Democrat mayor of Portland, who has watched
great death and destruction of his city during
his tenure, thinks this lawless situation
should go on forever.
Wrong.
Portland will never recover with a fool for
a mayor.
Remember, Trump is president now.
If Trump can stop the violence, why isn't
Trump stopping the violence or saying he won't
do it until he's reelected?
Very, very disturbing that that is not raising
a red flag with tens of millions of Trump
voters.
Trump also tweeting law and order in all capital
letters multiple times over the weekend.
Hundreds of tweets and read tweets, outrageous
behavior from a sitting president of the United
States